madame la Présidente Mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gabriel
Atal Premier ministre et ex-ministre de
l'éducation national au moment des faits
que je vais évoquer la veille de votre
nomination à matinon le journal médiap a
révélé que l'enquête administrative
annoncé dans la foulée du suicide du
jeune Lucas 13 ans n'a jamais eu lieu et
que celle menée par le parquet a été
bâlée interrogé fin 2023 monsieur hatal
désormais Premier ministre n'a jamais
voulu répondre et c'est pour cela que je
reposer la question devant la
représentation nationale à l'époque
l'émotion était vive et la déclaration
unanime des ancien ministre PAP à Marl
Chapa en passant par clé bon tous et
toutes tous et toutes expriment leur
sidération derrière l'émotion suscité
par ce drame survenu en janvier l'année
dernière rien n' été fait pour savoir si
le collège de l'adolescent aurait pu
prévenir ce suicide l'enquête
administrative annoncée et enterrée par
le princip et le princip
de l'établissement qui minimise les fait
de harcèlement n'a jamais été auditionné
l'homophobie l'attente dont était
victime le cas était en réalité
omniprésente dans l'établissement depuis
son arrivée le principal de
l'établissement a-t-il tenté de
préserver la réputation du collège qui à
livré de fauses informations ou à
minimisé les agissements des élèves mis
en cause malheureusement rien na été
fait pour poursuivre les coupable ma
question pourquoi cette enquête annoncée
par le gouvernement n'a jamais été
lancée pourquoi avoir communiqué sur une
enquête administrative qui n'a jamais
existé et oui très
bien je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Amélie oudea
Castera ministre en charge de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sports et des Jeux paralympiques madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés mesdames monsieur le député
Baptiste une école qui ne transige
jamais sur le respect de l'enfant et
s'oppose catégoriquement au harcèlement
pas plus qu'un enseignant un enfant ne
doit doit avoir peur à l'école il doit
s'y sentir bien vous évoquez le cas de
Lucas je veux plus largement évoquer
ceux de Linse de Nicola avoir une pensée
pour toutes les familles de victimes
depuis 6 ans vous le savez on a
considérablement renforcé notre action
contre le harcèlement notamment avec la
loi portée par le député balanan qui en
fait un délit et avec la mise en place
du programme fa le Premier ministre l'a
impulsé en mettant fin à cette are du
pas de vague il nous a donné la feuille
de route 100 % prévention 100 %
détection 100 % solution lors de la
journée non au harcèlement 7 millions
d'élèves du CE2 à la terminale ont
répondu à un questionnaire pour déceler
les situations de harcèlement et de
mal-être à l'école dans quelques jours
nous aurons la synthèse détaillée de
cette démarche qui est inédite et je
communiquerai une photographie qui est
claire qui est précise de où nous en
sommes dans les écoles et les
établissements ainsi que sur toutes les
enquêtes en cours les équipes éducatives
sont extrêmement mobilisées le ministère
les a armé au niveau des départements
des académies en déployant notamment 150
postes de responsables nous allons
avancer aider les parents d'élèves aussi
à mieux détecter les situations de
harcèlement aucune situation ne doit
rester sans réponse tant pour les élèves
victimes que pour les élèves auteurs que
nous pouvons désormais changer d'école y
compris dans le primaire l'école de la
République est une école qui doit
protéger qui rend heureux et il n'y aura
aucune exception à ce principe je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur le député madame
madame la ministre beaucoup d' fait
d'annonce mais très peu d'actes par
cette question je m'associe à la peine à
la peine des parents de Nicolas jeune
guadeloupéen qui s'est suicidé à poissi
dans les ivelines après s'être plein
l'année précédente de harcèlement mais
aussi des parents de Dina qui a mis fin
à ses jours après des faits similaires
au collège Émile Zola à kinc
merci merci beaucoup mon cher collègue